foreign
[Music]
thanks for joining us here today
I'm Chris Gord I am the senior director
of product for security operations here
at Google that's basically all of our
you know products that power you know
security operations detection and
response which is Chronicle Sim
Chronicle soar the mandian set of
products as well as our threat Intel
platform and virustotal I'm joined by
Eric Aldridge he's the head of security
engineering and security operations at
the CME Group he's one of our customers
that are on the security operations
transformation Journey with us and so
we're excited to have him here to talk a
little bit about what CME Group has gone
through and how they've transformed
their security operations
so I started my career my security
career back in 2004 at a company called
RSA security and the reality is I think
when you look about the past 20 years or
so we really haven't come that far as a
security industry in terms of solving
our core true operational Challenge from
a security perspective you know at RSA
we were a company that had probably a
pretty high degree of sophistication we
were a company that had a high degree of
tooling we were a company that had a
high degree of expertise in-house we
used to bring customers in to our
security operations center we used to
show off all the visibility all the
advancement all the capability that we
had internally but unfortunately in 2011
we were subjected to one of the largest
I would say most high profile breaches
that have occurred over the last you
know 20 years or so which was the RIT
RSA secure ID token breach there's a
really good wired article about it if
you really want to read and understand
what happened during the token breach
but the reality was you know we had a
team internally
that was tracking and looking at log
information
in a very highly manual and
labor-intensive way right again this is
back in 2011. and we were collecting a
lot of information but there was really
no understanding of truly what was
happening in the environment uh and the
attacker came into the environment in a
fairly non-sophisticated way it was a
standard fishing attack right and
ultimately they got a user to click on
something they shouldn't have clicked on
took advantage of a zero day exploit
after that made their way through the
back end systems of RSA you know
ultimately reached a database of 70
million secure ID token seats uh and it
was a you know sophisticated nation
state attacker and their goal was to
basically exfiltrate those token seeds
and try to break into US Government
Federal infrastructure by using secure
ID as kind of the the the door into
those environments
but the problem that we saw at the time
was that we really had no I think true
understanding
of how to under how to look at and
really evaluate whether an attacker was
sitting inside our environment and it
actually wasn't until we called in
mandian at the time again this is you
know back in 2011 to actually inform us
of all the in all the you know attack
patterns and all the attack paths that
the attacker actually went through that
we even understood exactly what happened
and again we were a company that did not
have uh any lack of sophistication from
a security perspective and the reason
why I bring this up is you know the
reality is we haven't come that far you
know the mandian M trans report if
you're interested in really
understanding what the attack landscape
looks like and what attackers are up to
on a regular basis I recommend that
everyone read that report it comes out
every year it's got a ton of good
statistics and understanding of what
attackers are up to this is a stat from
last year's you know the 20 or this
year's 2023 entrance report
63 percent of organizations or 63 of
incidents still result in external
entities
informing the organization that they've
been breached
and so you take you know 15 20 years of
innovation that we've had all of the
advancement and security operations
tooling all the advancement in how we
deal with you know adversary awareness
and you know sophisticated security
tools all the money that's gone into
security investment and the reality is
still in two-thirds of the cases
organizations don't even know they're
breached right and that's pretty
shocking like when you think about it
like we haven't come all that far from
an industry perspective uh even after
all this investment the other thing
that's interesting is that you know
adversaries are still pretty much using
similar techniques that they use you
know 15 20 years ago
like if you look at the M trans report
from last year over 50 percent of
incidents that occurred
came in through similar attack vectors
that we got breached in back in RSA you
know 15 years ago which is malware
exploitation and fishing
and you would think that we would have
solved those problems by now to be
honest with you I mean those are fairly
well understood attack vectors everyone
kind of knows what it's like to have you
know malware running in the environment
how to evaluate malware everyone knows
what fishing looks like but that's still
the vast majority of cases in terms of
how breaches are happening or how
breaches are getting into the system an
attackers you know they're just getting
used to getting around controls they
understand how to leverage you know
different types of techniques and and
different types of you know use cases to
get around common controls but I still
think we have a long way to come in
terms of just having our defense tooling
you know catching up to where we need to
get it to
the other thing is that you know
attackers are consistently innovating
even within those attack vectors right
and so if you look at the amount of new
malware families that are being
published every single year you know
over 588 new malware families were
identified forget about the ones that
were created just the ones that were
identified by malware uh by mandian uh
in the latest M trans report which is a
pretty shocking number if you compare
that back to where things were 10 years
ago it's probably 10x the number of
malware families that are being
identified on a regular basis and so the
reality is you know and this is no
surprise attacker is going to keep
innovating attackers are going to keep
advancing their their their approaches
even if they're using common techniques
they're going to keep trying to find
ways to get around what you need to what
you're doing to try to defend yourself
the other big reason I think that you
know we're seeing a lack of ability for
organizations to actually properly
defend themselves is to be honest there
are many ways using Legacy tooling
um I like to refer to Sims as being the
ultimate do-it-yourself tool
it's basically like here's a log
aggregation platform here's a way of
storing and collecting a bunch of
information
and then good luck everything else is up
to you and that's actually the exact
same thing we were doing back in 2011
when RSA was breached right it was we
were just collecting a lot of
information we had no idea what to look
for how to look for it you know we knew
a little bit we had some reasonable
reasonably good security analysts but
there wasn't any actually security
intelligence built into the to the SIM
and I think that's still largely where
things stand today with Legacy Sim
technology the reality is 95 of the
workflow is manual 95 percent of the
intelligence that you bring to the table
is done internally by the people that
are operating the Sim and we just
haven't seen an advancement to a more
outcome-oriented solution
uh I I kind of juxtaposed that a lot to
the endpoint space I think endpoint has
done a reasonably good job in advancing
from being just a forensic collection
platform to being an actual security
focused you know tool and really an
outcome oriented Tool uh and the reality
is I think we need Sims to kind of move
in that same direction and become more
outcome oriented in order for us to be
able to solve this problem
the second issue that he run into with
Sims is that even when you are just you
know trying to collect data and that's
all you're trying to do
99 times out of 100 you're not
collecting enough of it either because
of cost or scale reasons right so every
almost every single customer I talk to
for one reason or another they're
compromising the amount of information
that they're sending to their back-end
Sim you know either because they don't
feel like the SIM can handle it because
they're dealing with on-premise Legacy
infrastructure or because they just
don't want to pay the money because
they're being metered on an ingest basis
for every single piece of data that they
send into the SIM
the other analogy or another you know
story I like to use is I used to run
product for an endpoint detection and
response company before I joined Google
a couple years ago the number one
feature requests that I always got was
export data filtering
meaning that all customers wanted to do
is take all this good information that
we were collecting from an endpoint
perspective and filter it so that they
can send it to their Sim in a filtered
format just simply because they didn't
want to deal with the scale or cost
implications and I'm not talking about
alerting right you know it's fine to be
able to quiet down your alerts but I'm
just talking about raw forensic
information there was no reason that
people should have been filtering that
data before I got to the Sim because you
really want to use that for
investigation and forensics but the
reality is people you know really needed
to do that just simply from a cost and
scale perspective
and the last piece is like I mentioned
there's no like what I would call
outcome oriented solution right there's
no ability for you to a tie an
understanding of what attackers are
doing in traditional Sim environments
right you look at the leaders in the
same space not to pick on any individual
one but the reality is they're not truly
you know security companies that have a
real deep understanding of security
Behavior right and one of the main
reasons that we purchase mandians you
know last year was really so that we can
enhance our ability to truly understand
what attackers are up to enhance our
ability to truly deliver that on top of
a you know scalable data platform with
uh with Chronicle
and so when I look at you know where Sim
needs to go and where security
operations needs to go in the future it
really comes down to these five things
uh in our mind the first is you know it
sounds fairly simple but we need to stop
being reactive and we need to move into
a more proactive stance
I think you've seen a lot of this in
Cloud infrastructure and you've seen
this pretty well from a cloud
infrastructure point of view where
people are really pushing towards a more
proactive understanding of where risk
exists in your Cloud infrastructure
how your posture is kind of set up and
where you might have misconfigurations
and how do you patch the holes that
might exist in order for attacker not to
be able to get in the first place
we have to bring that level of awareness
into security operations right the
reality is you really don't have a lot
of context about the environment that
you're trying to protect in a
traditional Sim
from our point of view we're looking to
change that we're looking to really
bring that understanding proactively of
what adversaries are doing where you
might be exposed how do we validate that
your controls are in the right place at
the right time and how do we just and
understand based on business risk what
you should be most focused on at any
given time and do that proactively not
just reactively based on threat
the second is you know you just can't
everything can't be manual everything
can't be people dependent all the time
you obviously need to have really good
people sitting in front of the screen
but we have to bring some intelligence
into the equation but we also have to
bring some ability to remove manual
effort in manual toil
and you know we've all seen a lot of the
information about AI come out over the
last year the reality is there's a
significant amount of opportunity now
that exists with Advanced AI
functionality to really remove
a high degree of manual toil from
people's day-to-day lives in everyday
use cases like security operations
and I think we're starting to prove that
with a lot of the things that we're
integrating into everything you know all
the products around Google Cloud but
especially on the security side where we
can really get to the point where we
have ai guided and assisted
investigation and response right where
it's not just about a human needing to
you know use AI for one particular part
of the workflow but instead we actually
have a highly trained highly tuned AI
you know engine really guiding and
leading you toward an investigative path
which I'll talk about that more in a
second
the third is about moving away from just
having threat Intel feeds and just
overlaying thread Intel data in a more
what I would call blind fashion to
really applying thread Intel in a much
more curated outcome driven fashion
and what I mean by that is like it
should be mostly the job of the vendor
in my opinion to really apply thread
Intel in the right way
and that's not the way I think most
security operations organizations run
it's not the way most Sims run to be
honest with you most Sims are on you
know the whole idea of having a thread
Intel platform a tip that whole Market
exists because people are trying to
aggregate collect and align their threat
Intel feeds to make sense out of them
for their own Sim environment which by
definition is a really odd thing to ask
someone to do right we should be the
ones as vendors or other SIM vendors
should be the ones that are helping you
apply the right intelligence at the
right times right and we should be able
to do that through this notion of
curated outcomes so you just come in
flip a switch say you're looking to
understand the latest breach analytics
you want a mandated intelligence to be
applied across your data and we should
be able to do that in a much more
automated and much more curated fashion
the third is around you know driving
contextual awareness and contextual
information and when you're dealing with
investigation and response
and that it kind of moves away from this
notion of just dealing with alerts right
we don't want to obviously an alert is
the thing that you want to be able to
know to be able to be notified about but
the reality is we have to provide you
the right level of context when you're
performing your investigative tasks
one way we're doing this in chronicle
which I'll talk about in a second is
this idea of cloud detection and
response where when you're dealing with
a event or an alert inside of your Cloud
environment we actually augment and tell
you everything you need to know about
the contexts of that asset or that
entity that you're investigating around
and using that context you can make much
more well-informed decisions right and
we do that because we know a lot about
the environment in which you're
operating in because you're running
inside of Google Cloud but you can also
apply that same level of contextual
aware awareness anywhere in the
infrastructure as long as we bring in
the right level of information
and then the last piece is you should
never have to worry about being capacity
constrained or cost constraint right
that should not be a consideration that
ever has to enter into a Security
operation professional's mind
and so that's one thing I think we've
solved right from the beginning with
Chronicle which is just you flip the
switch it's a SAS driven surface it's
what we call infinitely scalable it runs
on the same backbone that search and
YouTube and Gmail run on top of and so
we have the ability of just dealing with
large data volumes searching through
those data volumes at a way higher you
know performance rate than any other
vendor that's out there today
uh and so what we've done with the uh
the integration Chronicle
simplify which was now renamed Chronicle
soar the mandian portfolio is Rel as
well as our Intel information that have
come from Google's internal threatened
threat analysis group as well as
virustotal just kind of integrated all
this into one overall overarching
security operations platform
uh and the reality is you know we're
able to cover a pretty wide swath of all
the things that I talked about you know
previously by combining all these
Technologies together and really running
on top of the world's most scalable data
Lake and Chronicles from the ground up
and there's kind of Three core things
that I would always point to and and
customers ask like what are the big
things that Chronicle does that's
different than what you're what you're
going to get in market today the first
is
just that ability to run and operate at
Google scale and Google speed
right so I mentioned the fact that
Google was you know Chronicle was built
from the ground up on top of the same
infrastructure that powers our
consumer-facing applications uh and
that's true like one of the interesting
tidbits about Chronicle was actually
developed for an internal use case
inside of Google to be able to power our
own internal security operations and it
was actually built before Google Cloud
was kind of even a thing and so we built
it on top of an infrastructure core
called Borg inside of Google which is
the same backbone that runs our
consumer-facing applications and so we
can you know we've proven I think pretty
consistently that we can pull in and
scale large amounts of information store
that information for 12 months by
default in hot storage and search
through that information faster than any
other vendor that's out there
and right there you get a pretty you
know you know amazing benefit which is
the fact that you don't have to worry
about filtering information arbitrarily
and we can deliver that to you at a cost
profile that's way more attractive than
what you're going to get with other
vendors because we're operating on top
of our own infrastructure
the second piece is we're able to take
what I believe is the world's best
threat intelligence you know bar you
know I think almost definitely more than
any other SIM vendor out there but I
would argue over any other even security
vendor out there and we're able to apply
that on top of your data at high degrees
of scale
and so when I talk about the world's
best and threat intelligence I want you
to think about a few things first think
about the breadth of information that
Google has access to
I think there's 2.5 billion or so
um people in the world that are using
Chrome on a daily basis
that's like you know 30 of the world's
population uh every single day using
Chrome browsers
Google is able to understand and see
attacker activity and the attack surface
across that level of scale through you
know initiatives like safe browsing
we're actually looking at malware
downloads you know through Chrome we're
able to do that through Gmail by
evaluating phishing attacks and so when
you have this wide scale of billions of
users and you have the ability of
understanding the attacker landscape
across that level of population it's
very very very unlikely that any other
specific security vendor could even come
close to that level of breadth and we've
always had that level of breath you know
inside of Google and we store all that
information in a back-end uh you know
team called Tac which is the threat
analysis group inside of Google
a few years ago probably 10 years ago we
augmented that by buying virustotal
virus total is the world's preeminent
malware and ioc you know reputation
database it Aggregates information
across you know every single AV vendor
every single you know
um uh you know vendor that's sending in
domain-based information about ioc about
ioc and you know potential attack
vectors there and I think we have over
2.4 billion entries inside of Iris tool
and so we have a fairly wide footprint
just understanding the attack landscape
and the attack surface just given that
level of breadth right there's not many
other vendors that can look at that
level of breath across the board
with mandian what we're able to do is
augment that with a significant amount
of depth right and so what mandian does
is tracks specific threat actor Behavior
it tracks specific threat campaigns you
know they have direct researchers that
are out there looking at specific
attacker activity and they're proving
that like on the front lines by actually
operating real incident response
engagements with customers every single
day
and so when you combine that level of
breaths with that level of depth that
Mandy and is bringing to the table
in my opinion and I think an opinion of
most of the people inside of Google
you're going to get the world's best
threat intelligence
and the idea is not just to have that
thread Intel and hand it to a customer
and say figure it out yourself the idea
is to what we call apply that threat
intelligence inside a product
and what we mean by that is every single
event that comes into Chronicle we want
to enrich and augment that event
with threat intelligence from the ground
up
you know we could be ingesting trillions
of events for any given customer at any
given time every single one of those we
want to run through our threat Intel
platforms we want to see if it's
associated with the malware family we
want to see if it's associated with the
campaign we want to see if it's
associated with a threat actor and then
we want to take the metadata that we see
about Association and append it to the
event so that you have it as part of
your core investigative workflow every
time you have an event inside a
Chronicle
we then want to also do analysis on top
of those events to see if any of those
things we think are highly indicative of
active breaches and that's a feature
inside of Chronicle that we call breach
Analytics
and so that's what I mean by applied
threat intelligence when you're dealing
with you know number one needing to have
access to the world's best Intel but
number two needing to apply that access
at scale I really don't think any other
SIM vendor out there is coming close to
what we're able to do inside of
Chronicle from that perspective
and then the third is this notion of AI
infused productivity right and so all
the things that you're seeing with chat
CPT all the sort of momentum that's been
happening around AI lately all of that
has really been technology and
capability that was first researched
and open source by Google back in 2017.
and so you know
I think it's almost it's fairly easy to
say that if anyone can apply large-scale
AI approaches into security and do it
well uh that Google is a great
organization to be able to do that and
the reality is in order for you to be
able to apply AI at scale and do it well
you're going to need to do that on top
of large amounts of information and so
the chronicle value proposition kind of
feeds on itself here because the more
information that we have at any given
time to be able to train the model the
better off we are in actually operating
you know true AI advancement on top of
customer security operations profile
here's just the proof point from one of
our customers and talking talking about
how Chronicles reduced mean time to
resolution I love this quote it's one of
the things that we take most pride in
which is how do we help a customer
actually tangibly improve their return
on investment and actually really help
them reduce mean time to resolution and
the reality is when you stack a lot of
these capabilities and these benefits
together you start to see really true
tangible results from customers like
this who are you know truly able to
demonstrate and measure how they see
security operations changing inside
their environment
I talked about our ability to apply
Intel here's some you know additional
statistics the big thing I like to point
out here is just the size of the
mandiant research team and so not only
do we run over 1400 incident response
engagements a year where we're out there
in the trenches with customers operating
the latest and greatest incidents but we
also have I think a world-class if not
the best research team that's performing
direct Intel research every single day
with over 500 analysts and so probably
the two biggest breaches that you've
heard about over the last you know three
or four or five years which is the log
for Jay breach and the solarwinds breach
both of those things were identified the
campaign families the attackers and the
techniques row identified by that
mandian research team right and so these
are the kind of people that are working
every single day to really bring and
apply those threat intelligence
capabilities into Chronicle and into
security operations at Google
this is just an example of cloud
detection and response you know I know a
lot of the rooms probably Google Cloud
customers and this is just a way in
which we bring contextual awareness to
the equation to help you perform your
detection and response activities right
and the reality is what we're able to do
is take our understanding of the
attacker landscape
deliver curated detections inside of
Chronicle where I can just simply flip a
switch and turn on cloud detections but
then when I do see alerts I'm able to
leverage the context the understanding
of the infrastructure and Landscape to
make it easier for you to Pivot and
understand what that alert really means
in context right which machine is it on
What entity is it on what is that entity
performing what is it connected to
what's the associated risk of that
entity right and how important is it for
me to deal with this incident right now
all those things are what we mean by
contextual awareness right and that's
what you know effectively is bubbled up
into Cloud detection and response
the other thing that we announced
yesterday is something called Mandy and
hunt for chronicle
this is where we take that really
powerful team of 500 analysts and Intel
researchers that are on the back end we
have a team that's performing
operational kind of detection and
response every day for for hundreds of
customers and what we do is we layer
that on top of Chronicle information and
so if you're a Chronicle customer inside
your Chronicle tenant you can
effectively have the mandian team
perform what we call silent hunting
where they deploy a set of hunting rules
they deploy a set of emerging threat
indicator rules and they effectively
just perform it ongoing threat hunts to
look for attacker activity happening in
your environment and if they see
anything they can bubble that right up
to you and basically alert you that
there's something significant that you
should look at so this is a great way of
you know what I would call getting that
operational outcome
by leveraging the world's best experts
on top of it platform that's scalable
for the future
and then the last thing I'll point out
before Eric comes up here and talks
about his journey is you know what we've
delivered with duet Ai and Chronicle
right uh and this is you know I think a
capability that right now is what I
would call human lead and AI assisted
where the human is actually prompting
the llm and the SEC Palm model behind
the scenes to basically make it easier
to perform tasks that are somewhat
cumbersome and manual in nature to
perform like writing searches in our
search language which is Unified data
model or like writing rules in our rule
language which is URL
while those things are doable it's much
easier to be able to ask a machine to do
it and do it very quickly
where we're going with this is actually
really pushing it Beyond just being
human-led and AI assisted to what we
call you know AI guided based
investigation so what we've done is
we've trained the SEC Palm model
with basically every single research
report that mandian has published with
everything that exists inside a
virustotal and so think about the duet
AI capability in chronicle as being the
world's best threat researcher and
threat analyst sitting right alongside
un product and so as we move into next
year what you'll start to see in this
investigation panel on the right hand
side is it prompting you on things that
you should look at in your data set
based on what it sees as potential
malicious activity
and that's what we mean by AI guided
based investigation where it's actually
helping you along the way and making you
better at your job on a regular basis
and these are the kind of things that
honestly I don't think any other vendor
can really come close to mostly because
they don't have the Intel to be able to
train the model but also just because
they don't have the AI capability to be
able to deliver it
so that said you know uh it's one thing
to listen to me but it's also a much
better thing to listen to customers talk
about their Journey so I just want to
welcome Eric on the stage to talk about
CME
[Applause]
thank you Chris good morning everybody
I've been looking forward to this for a
while and I want to thank Google and
Chris and googler partners for the
opportunity to share with you uh cme's
journey through uh modernizing and
security operations
with its 175 year history CME Group is a
place where the world comes to manage
risk
using our Benchmark products our
customers can trade options Futures
optimize portfolios
and analyze vast data sets
my name is Eric Aldrich and I am part of
CME group's information security team
um
I work with technology and Business
Leaders in throughout CME Group to help
see me safely take advantage of new
business opportunities
what I'd like to share with you today is
our journey as we modernize our security
operations where we're still early in
our journey but we like what we're
seeing and I think we're headed in the
right direction
so first I'd like to go through some of
the drivers that we have considered both
internally and externally as we're kind
of establishing that Journey I'd like to
talk about some of the principles that
we used for our planning to sort of
Center ourselves as we as we move
forward
I'd like to share some of the outcomes
that that we're expecting out of that
Journey as we move through using the
people process and Technology framework
then I'd like to kind of share how we've
stacked up some of the deliverables uh
um that we're going to be performing
through our journey and then I'll then
I'll close
so CME has embarked on a digital
transformation right
um with its partner Google in this
transformation and
one of the things that we're looking for
is new ways of providing value
and Innovation to our customers at a
pace that we can increase right so that
our digital transformation allows us to
provide value new products to our
customers more quickly
so my team is responsible for helping to
you know safely
um
uh allow the business to move into those
new opportunities so we had to
carefully think about how we were going
to help the business approach it digital
transformation
so one of the things that we focused on
was really what the value of our
business our security business within
CME Group what did we want that value to
be
because we needed to ground what we were
doing
um
in certain principles that would help us
move forward and we knew that we we
would have some failures but that we
needed these principles and values to
make sure that we were always able to
Center ourselves on our journey
so the values that we
typically the value for an information
security team might be expressed is you
know to protect the confidentiality
integrity and availability of your
company's data and systems
I would argue that that is that is
important but it doesn't fully Express
what the value of a security team can
provide and that is
as Chris mentioned you know focusing
more on the outcomes that that the
business wants and the businesses
ability to compete through providing
Innovation and new products to its
customers
so
and then so we focused on what that
value would be and what we would need to
do in order to uh focus on on delivering
that value and and as uh analogy I like
to use to illustrate that is is the
difference between a guard dog and a
sheepdog right
a gordo goes to work every day expecting
its environment to be exactly the same
as it was the day before the week before
the month before the guard dog has a
bunch of infrastructure that it uses to
protect the environment as a fence
outside of the fence and inside of the
fence it has a building maybe the the
crown jewels right and and the guard dog
is good at that right that's that's a
that's been a good kind of structure but
what if the opportunities of that
business move elsewhere what if the
customers move elsewhere that's not a
model that is really going to help that
business compete and and safely provide
new innovation to its customers
the Sheepdog on the other hand goes to
work every day knowing expecting that
its environment is going to change and
it has built change and Dynamics into
the way that it's it protects the flock
right so that flock can move to New
Opportunities any day if that's what's
needed and the in the Sheepdog
understands how to manage risk for that
flock in a way that brings the risk
profile within the company's risk or the
flocks risk appetite so to speak
so so part of what we needed to do is
really understand where the value is and
change our culture and our mindset in
providing that value and so we needed to
rethink the way that we were doing that
our macro world I mean let's be real
here right it can be crazy right if you
think about all the external factors
that that create threats for us the
slightest little kind of uh Global
events creates a Cascade of fishing
emails and cyber attacks that we have to
protect ourselves against the
Technologies are constantly changing
and if you think about where we're
actually doing work and where our data
is it's everywhere on anything at any
time right so that's an external risk
that we needed to to provide safe passes
for so to speak for a company
Talent as well is you know this is not a
new issue for any of us we all know that
um
we all need time you know uh cyber staff
and there's a lot of openings that are
just uh unfilled right you know I've
heard here in a couple of sessions that
there are hundreds of thousands if not
you know millions of openings that can't
be filled
part of the reason for that is because
we sort of need these cyber security
unicorns right and there there's just
not enough of them
um and so you know information security
unfortunately is still a bit of a black
art like you still need people who are
very well versed you know very tenured
and well-versed in you know security
protocols and network protocols and
attackers and all this stuff
rate of change is also something that is
uh you know a risk as well right because
if you think about how technology and
the way that we work has changed over
the last decade right you know we had
first moving from on-prem to Cloud then
we had our supply chain moving to the
cloud and then we had you know uh we had
the pandemic and everybody's working
from home uh and then you have machine
learning AI generative AI all these new
things that are creating risks
constantly
rate of change has another side to it
that probably should have been included
on on the first slide but rate of change
is a risk for my team if we can't change
at the rate that the company wants to
change so if we can't provide security
services at the rate that the company
needs to provide value to its customers
we become a blocker so from that's a
risk that we're trying to address as
well
so when we were talking about the
journey and the plan that we wanted to
create we we identified some principles
and I won't read everything on this
slide here but we identified some
important principles again so that we so
that we knew that this is a long journey
and we're just starting out and we knew
that we would go up path right so we
needed some principles to be able to
bring us back to our bearing
and and and some of those principles are
here so one of the most important ones
that we identified was if you're doing
something today don't don't continue
that right because that thing that
you're doing today
you designed it for a legacy environment
right and you don't want to carry that
over into the new way of of being more
flexible and providing value to the
business you need we need to be more
dynamic in things that we that we
created in in the
Legacy or traditional version of
ourselves likely wouldn't carry forward
so sometimes you're in a meeting when
you hear somebody say hey we've always
done it that way
that's a huge red flag right so we want
to make sure that we're being proactive
about identifying things that we need to
change
again we need to understand who our
customers are within the business we're
business within CME Group and we have
various customers we have business
customers you know my engineering team
has the sock is a customer right and so
we need to focus on what those
particular business customers needed and
when they needed the rate that they
needed it and so and and how Dynamic we
needed to be in doing that we need to
make sure that we were doing that in a
safe way
the other principle is we need to
prepare our teams for this change this
is a this is really about a cultural
change a way of sharing the impact that
we want to have with the business
so moving away from that kind of like
we're providing confidentiality
integrity and availability and expanding
that to provide
safe deployments of of new features and
Innovation to our customers at the rate
that the business needs to do it and we
needed to really work with our teams to
get out of that
I'm creating a I'm task based I'm
creating the security widget to really
having a broader mindset to say how is
what I'm doing today going to make the
business successful
we wanted to move away from the
waterfall kind of project-based kind of
deploying these you know eight 12 month
long projects right we needed to break
the if we're going to be more Dynamic we
needed to break our services up into
chunks that could be delivered to the
business on an incremental basis so that
the business can move as quickly as it
needed to move so we needed to to learn
how to iterate we needed to learn to be
comfortable with dropping in a minimum
viable product versus this gigantic
12-month project and and that works
because the business is iterating as
well and so we allow the business to
drop in their MVP we put in our MVP and
we make sure that we're that what we're
putting in obviously needs to reduce the
risk of that that deployment within our
risk appetite but you will find ways to
break up your services and your products
into ways that allows them to be
deployed in a way that allows the
business to be dynamic
of course we need to increment those
things and we so we need to have a
system we where CME Group is using the
agile methodology now to to make sure
that we can we can be dynamic with the
business and we're working in the same
kind of cadence and cycle that the
business is and we want to keep things
moving we want those increments to keep
happening so that we keep adding
maturity to those
to those deployments those initial
deployments
finally we want to delete things and and
by deleting I don't mean like
hey we're not really doing this anymore
so maybe we shouldn't anymore what I
mean is proactively looking for things
hunting for things that you can kill and
the reason you need to do that is
because those are consuming resources
that you can reapply into your
transformation
and so that's important so that you can
find those things in cultural the way
that people think about what they're
providing you can you can find that in a
procedural that technical debt and
financial debt all these things have
areas that you can hunt for and reapply
those Investments
so we talked a little bit about the
drivers and
um now these are I'll share with some of
the outcomes that we're looking for
using people process technology
we want to make sure that our people as
I mentioned before are outcome oriented
that they're looking for the complete
picture they're not creating you know
security widgets you know blind to what
what what their impact to the business
is we need to make sure that everybody
on the team knows what the business goal
is and that they're supporting that in
their role in security
we need to make sure that our people are
empowered right that we don't have to
have
people working in a vertical
organization Silo that has to ask
permission from their manager to go talk
to another department right so as part
of our agile transformation we're also
creating horizontally based teams that
have all the skill sets needed to create
Solutions without having to spend a lot
of time escalating and they can solve
problems in the two experience that they
have and that helps us be very Dynamic
and and help the business uh being
provide value to our customers
with the empowerment comes
accountability right and so with that
with those horizontal teams that are
accountable for delivering on uh on the
planning and you know there are lessons
that we'll learn from that and we'll
reapply that into the process
we want to relocate
uh our people's value right we want to
get our people into the ooda loop as
quickly as possible Right like we we
need security unicorns because there's a
lot of manual toil context generation
summarization you have to you have to
know how to connect all that data that's
in your sim and you need a very tenured
person in order to be able to do that
effectively in a way that you can
protect your company we want to be able
to democratize access to that analysis
and decision-making phase to maybe
people that might not be as tenured that
might be more Junior right so that we
can have a we can have easier access to
um
you know uh security candidates right
security team members and we also can
keep our humans in the place that
they're best at right people people get
burned out and and they leave because of
the manual work that they have to do and
they're not in the space that they're
good at which is analysis and decision
making
um process outcomes that we wanted we
wanted our process to be dynamic we want
them to provide a lot of context and we
wanted them to be extremely queryable
and some of the tools that Google
provides the clinical Sim and the
natural language processing you know
we've been able to begin using some of
these tools that provide this Rich data
set and keep our analysts in that ooda
Loop more often we want our processes to
also be coded and unsupervised we have a
lot of documentation we have hundreds of
triage procedures run books Play Books
incident response procedures many of
those things can be automated and so we
want an outcome that we want our
processes is to take as much of that
stuff that is wrote and can be put into
code and do that we want to make sure
that those things are measured and
optimized so that we can take those
learnings and improve our processes and
so we've kind of recoined the SR the
site reliability engineering term to
kind of security reliability engineering
on our team payments so we want to make
sure that we're measuring those things
as well so that we can always be
learning and improving
for technology that's the dessert for
most of us that's the thing that we
always run to first it's fun to play
with the technology and and we have as
well but we want to make sure that our
technology is
um is really being driven by the first
two people in process and supporting
those things and so we want our we want
our technology to be process oriented we
don't we don't want technology silos we
open Point solution we want a process of
protection what's the outcome that we
want out of that process and we want
tools that can support that and
Chronicle Sim has that broad visibility
across the Enterprise field of view so
that as our company is connecting
together the the Google services that
we're using to create innovation of
products those things automatically flow
into uh into the systems that we're
using with Google Chronicle soar uh ueba
tools right those things automatically
come in and we don't need to spend a lot
of time building infrastructure to
protect those things
finally we want the technology to
provide context we want the ability for
those you know we will need extremely
tenured people but we also want the more
Junior people to be able to perform
effectively as well and so we want to
make sure that the technology we're
using like the duet Ai and some of the
some of the other features that are
being added to Chronicle Sim we want to
make sure that those things enable you
know democratize access to the security
functions of to more of our team
so quickly on our transformation of
modern operations
um we we stacked up
um we stacked our deliverables into four
phases and between uh those phases we
also have some Applause right so that we
can internalize and build muscle memory
and train on what we learned in in the
in each of the phases and essentially
phase one is really about delivering
that mvp
putting an initial set of context in
there uh discovering the differences or
the gaps between what you're doing in
your on-prem environment and and how you
would need to refactor and transform
those things into the clinical Sim
environment then we paused we did a
bunch of testing Google was you know
very a very good partner as far as
helping us to create excuse me training
and capture the flags so that we could
build that muscle memory and our and our
team could learn what this stuff
actually looks like in the real world
and then phase two was about building on
that content adding some maturity
um you know moving to Agile for our team
as well and we're in the middle of phase
two and phase three right now phase
three is going to be about
adding more automation moving more uh
more firmly towards autonomous sock
operations adding machine learning and
artificial intelligence just learning
how to use AI workbench and some of the
tools that we're previewing right now
and maturing our use of these products
and then
phase four is really about normalizing
all these things and making them become
BAU so that we could run them on our own
and then sort of getting the keys handed
over towards us so that we can you know
carry that forward into BYU state
so putting it all together
it this is a this is really about a
mindset shift for our team right the
technology obviously important and and
we're using that but it's really about
having your team understand what the
outcome is that the team needs to have
and that is a broad business outcome
uh planning is a key to success in in
that we have to make sure that we have a
plan and some principles so that if we
come off course that we're guided back
on and then just you know then execute
thank you very much and I'm going to
hand this back to Chris I think
[Applause]
another survey and please you know give
us some feedback I don't think we have
any time for live questions but Eric and
I will both be up here after the session
so if you're interested in ask us any
questions by all means come up when
happy to chat and thanks again for
everyone taking the time to join us this
morning we appreciate it